who really creates jobs because the way
you and I look at this is the way you
are not going to vote next year who
creates jobs see a lot of people want to
tell us the government creates jobs some
people want to tell us corporations big
companies create jobs and some people
want to tell us people create jobs so
who really creates jobs because the
reality of it is who wants more jobs we
all want more jobs we all want to have
more jobs for who for us and our kids if
our kids don't have jobs who is
supporting them we are supporting them
what if I told you today that 100
percent of all jobs in America can be
traced back to the origins of an
entrepreneur would you debate that it's
okay if you do who would debate that a
couple of you would debate that because
some people will say well have our
military entrepreneurs don't pay
military how about cops they're
government workers the government pays
their salary
no that's not true let's look at this
let's look at this there once was a lady
or a man with a what she decided to take
that idea and start a what the business
started slowly growing she realized she
needs what when she realized she needs
help she started looking for who people
when she started hiring people what does
she create when you create jobs what do
employees pay every year taxes goes to
who government gives us what military
firefighter police school roads etc
without you and I there are none of
those things let me take you back to
here so you see how I'm processing this
let's say all of us here decide to start
a new country called Fontana will you
okay with that we're starting Fontana
Ville okay and I want you to visualize
this for a quick second the 400 of us we
have just found Fontana this is 300
years ago we're all escaping some other
city we find ourselves here and we just
saw each other for the first time what's
the reaction gonna be what are you
coming from who are you
what were you from you're good are we
good is that your family hey give me a
handshake you're good hey good to me
okay good this guy's safe and we can are
very what at first
then we calm down a little bit then we
start a country what's the first thing
you think we do let me tell you what's
the first thing we do here's what we do
hey what do you good at I'm good at
sewing clothes all we need clothes cuz
we got a lot of kids that are cold are
you pretty fast at it yes how many can
you do a day okay good
what do you get at I'm not good at a lot
of things but I got eight counts
we need cows milk is good milk is very
good okay good what do you get at I'm
good at making Spears all we need Spears
because if by any chance
Riverside Villa taxes we gotta get them
I'm telling you so we need some Spears
hey what do you get at I'm good at
healing if a person gets a wound or a
cut I know how to deal with it okay good
what do you get out under this I'm not
gonna let a lot of things but I got 22
chickens chickens eggs are good good
eggs great what do you get at we start
talking then eventually you know what
happens Michael looks at understands hey
Michael check the under let's check this
out I got six kids man and I need some
eggs and I need about two eggs per kid
and myself and my wife which is about 14
eggs a day how much milk you need you
give me two gallons of milk I'm gonna
give you what 14 eggs a day
great deal okay great she says hey you
know what men are kids we need some
Spears man imma my boys they're tough
but I need some Spears they have no
weapons I'll give you Spears what will
you do for us my wife is not feeling
well can you come and check right I will
what do you get out we start doing what
we start trading now watch what happens
then a bully shows up and here's what
happens
Michael Michael says yes
give me your eight cows and Michael says
what no give me your cows no and a bully
takes away what the cows then we need a
government then we need a government not
the other way around and you know who
would typically vote as our president of
our country Fontana Ville does anybody
know who we vote and what quality we
look for what quality thing we look for
first thing we look for is trust you
know why because in the country of four
hundred people who knows about
everybody's business everybody knows
about everybody's business and we elect
that person that we all trust as our
president
that's how countries are started but you
know what TV and medium politicians are
telling us
they're telling us all the problems in
America are gonna be fixed this way and
you know what's insane we're buying it
we are buying it I'm an immigrant I came
to America because I wanted to be left
alone I wanted to be free and you know
what why most Americans come white most
immigrants come to America they don't
come to America for the benefits all
immigrants come to America because they
want social security and free health and
no they don't they want to come here
because they want their kids to be free
and they want free enterprise freedom of
religion freedom of assembly they want
freedom is why they come here but
because TV and media is becoming so big
you and I we sit just like this and we
watch the TV and whoever is on TV we
think that person is God and they know
more than you and I do and we say oh
let's have it make all the decisions for
our lives nope
for years you know who's ranked
countries for yours who we have because
who is smarter than 50 people combined
nobody if we put our minds together and
we have gotten away from that a little
bit